[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we have an episode today where we're
going to be talking about food the
future of food we're gonna be talking
about eating insects we have Lord sorrow
all right thank you for joining us
thanks for having me
really appreciate you coming on the show
you are co-founder of chirps chips
indeed yes and the CEO you have a lot of
operations to be doing to make people
excited about sex so what the hell
eating insects right the world's been
doing this for a while what the West is
like the starting now yeah it's kind of
an interesting history there I first saw
you guys you and rose on Shark Tank yet
what's that two years ago now last
January last year so January 2007 year
and a half yeah yeah your and a half ago
and Laura's really funny is you burst
through the whatever the part that you
guys said would trick although you run
through a banner for a football game
exactly I had a cricket costume on and
that burst through in surprise the
Sharks though I don't get the scare
celebrities a lot so that was cool I
think you scared Barbara right yeah yeah
yeah that's that's right I didn't
remember that okay and so then you guys
successfully pitch them we did yes and
raise funding from Mark Cuban yes indeed
and now you're Mark Cuban company we are
now we were keeping company yeah well I
guess you're not bought by him but yeah
part of you guys my soul yet and he has
helped you guys a lot with what you're
doing yeah I'm surprised right because
you're like am I ever going to hear from
the Sharks again but every week we send
him an update awesome he always writes
us back and he's got kind of a team of
other people to help us so yeah it's
been good yeah Cuban companies he
recently wrote something super
interesting which was that he loves
hiring people that take stress away from
him about like know him safe
I'm in like that I'm like that's totally
something that really vibes with a lot
of people that are building meetings is
if you can take away for example with
you guys as well as if you can find
someone that's gonna take a good
workload off of you that does it well
like that you'll pay a lot of money to
get you know I can do that we've been
doing a lot of hiring lately it's been
amazing in fact I'm actually not doing
much operations anymore because we
brought on someone who's even better and
more experienced so yeah goodness for
that you can work on some of the vision
now more of the vision so okay so you
and Rose met at Harvard and then you had
both been traveling this is such an
interesting story so you were traveling
your African Studies yes major
and then you travel to where an African
8th batter pillar yes Tanzania rural
Tanzania which is a beautiful oh so
pretty yeah one of my favorite spot and
you ate a caterpillar I did who is a
group mostly vegetarian and so when I
was in Tanzania and I came across this
street vendor selling Frank caterpillars
I had two thoughts going on and I had
one with is this vegetarian do I eat it
and then the other one which is more
common to everyone which is I really
want to eat a bug right it's worried it
looks like a worm but I did I bought it
and I bit down and my first thought was
this tastes like Lobster
uh-huh it's actually really good and so
started me questioning like why are
people eating bugs in Tanzania
why aren't they eating in the United
States and why does this actually taste
good and and this is this is like at the
same time that we're right around the
same time then Rose went somewhere else
in the world and was interesting
scorpion yes so I got really excited
about this I'm the kind of person who
reads about something gets obsessed so I
got back from Tanzania and just started
doing research and when you type in
eating insects you come up with all of
these amazing statistics around how
healthy how sustainable it is I mean
it's just blowing my mind I'll throw in
one stat here I won't bore you to death
but for example to make one pound of
beef it makes about two
I was in gallons of water to make a
pound of crickets it takes about one
gallon of water
so like orders of magnitude more
sustainable and so I didn't this thought
tasted good and was like we got to do
this we gotta start eating bugs and so I
sent an article to my college roommate
Rose about eating insect and Holly would
have thought it was a like a little
loopy right except that she had been in
Beijing that summer and in Beijing
there's a street market like a night
market where you can get fried scorpions
and so she had been dared ate a fried
scorpion had a similar reaction of me
which was this tastes like shrimp and so
we kind of came together over these
shared experiences and started trying to
answer this question of how do we get
other people to eat bugs and what does
this look like yeah and okay this is
funny because you guys both made seafood
embarrassing yeah it makes sense right
so it basically both like shrimp
lobsters in fact they're all arthropods
so they're really all in one big family
in fact sometimes we call crickets land
shrimp because they are so closely
related hmm interesting so this was part
of the natural evolution of species on
the planet as we migrated from ocean
land then some of the traits arthropods
carried here you don't why it's an
interesting mix where it's you know
arthropods on land and in the ocean so
yeah and is this also you you or don't
we see those critters that are also on
top of water that jump kind of like oh
cricket does a little stream yeah
they've got like a water Cedars there's
different names friends yes interesting
okay and so then the do you guys but you
guys ended up not doing the classic Ola
drop out and go do this you guys both
still finish yes I originally ate
insects when I was still in school but
you know I spent went on and there were
more and more articles about it and so
it was actually after I graduated that I
was like let's go full in and Roseville
had a semester left so she she was still
in school and we officially started like
burn time um but yeah I mean at first we
didn't know what we want to me right
like this big question of how do we get
people to eat bugs
it was unclear the first thing we didn't
could have easily started with cookies
but you decided to serve with chips I
mean take a step back further than that
you weren't sure me we thought at first
maybe people would just be buggy bugs I
mean that's how they eat them all over
the world yeah and so we went to the
local pet stores like a Petco and bought
every kind of insect we could get our
hands on wax worms and mealworms and all
these kinds of bugs that are perfectly
edible but are normally fed to lizards
for example and we fried them up and
tried to feed them to our friends and
what do you think happen they were like
it's kind of they're more hesitant if
they're not in a form that's relatable
to them like a chip is yeah people were
pretty scared by the fact that we were
trying to feed them whole in zag yeah
and so it was pretty clear pretty
quickly that that just wasn't gonna work
it makes sense if you think about
American people right like we don't eat
whole cows we don't eat whole pigs we're
probably not gonna eat whole insects and
so you're right that became the question
of what form is this go in and we have
some other examples of food that has
been introduced by changing the form for
example if I were to ask you if you were
wanted to eat raw fish you might have
hesitations but it's if it's in sushi
people are all about it and so we use
examples like sushi and there's all
sorts of interesting things yeah I think
I would just start eating a uncooked
piece of salmon fork and knife but if
you wrap a tiny piece of that in some
rice and some avocado yeah I'm more
likely to eat it right interesting well
that kind of became the question of we
know this is possible what do we do with
the form and so we went through
different iterations we rounded up and
made kind of a meat out of it for a
little bit and then we eventually landed
on oh well there's a picture this is
cricket flour cricket powder it has
different names know what it is it's
just it gets dried and milled into a
super high protein nutritious powder and
as Americans we put all sorts of weird
powders in our food right we put flowers
as well as protein powders so this was a
form that Americans begin and started to
make that transition between thinking of
insects as something that is a past
something you might
under your bed to thinking of it as a
food source and that was the goal is how
do you make that and then does this do
they need to be frozen first or they do
yes so I mean that's a good question so
basically we can get into how cricket
farming works but basically yes the
crickets are grown and then they're
cold-blooded so you freeze them so they
go to sleep there all the blood is yes
yeah our most insect all of them are and
that means is that closer to like 40
degrees Fahrenheit or it just means that
they don't regulate their own
temperature it's kind of the environment
so actually an interesting fact about
crickets is you can tell how hot it is
outside based on how fast they're
tripping and that has a food to do with
the temperature teach us about that you
know I don't know the exact ingredient
you can look at but you pay more chirps
during one of the two older faster the
faster they're tripping the hotter it is
outside and you can use it as a pretty
accurate thermometer and they'll stop
tripping after it gets too cold you know
slow down and so yeah so that that's
what happens you know naturally when it
gets pulled out the quickest will fall
asleep and not wake up I know the end of
the season
crickets are rubbing their legs yeah
yeah I just imagine like you know like
the robber like rubbing your legs so
that's so interesting and so okay so
then that makes the noise and that noise
is usually used for some sort of maybe
link yeah okay okay and so cold-blooded
so then you're freezing so this is so
there's different places in the world
the history of this so interesting the
different place in the world of eating
insects for a really long time and do we
know how back off our back this is dated
like thousand years this is like the
most paleo food you can possibly imagine
right we've been eating them since their
before were humans all of our closest
relatives all the greats like taking it
from the skin and eating is interesting
so billions of years yes ma'am we have
in enzyme that specifically meant for
breaking down
in exact like I spell that to your you
know don't ask me spell it you can look
it up and it's a pro teets approach it
what is it basically yes you was given
enzyme to break down the kite which at
the outside of the bug they're like
crunchy shell okay um interesting and
okay so we have the ability yes which
means that like were built to eat inside
in fact the first creature that had
forward-facing eyes and opposable thumbs
was an insectivore meaning it only eight
in say and throughout an entire
evolutionary history we've been eating
bugs and even to this day more people
eat insects been speaking with so so
there's like a billion people that speak
english and then there's like two
billion people that eat bugs or
something exactly yeah interesting two
two and half billion people are eating
insects regularly I've seen all those
images of those markets that just have
like insects in the markets yeah
and I'm just like whoa a normal thing
like where we see vegetables and fruits
we don't have farmers markets of insect
yet maybe one day and you know West we
will and that was an interesting
question for me when I first got back
from Tanzania it's like why are we not
eating insect here in the United States
and it turns out that actually the
Native Americans even ate insect and
when the Europeans came over the Native
Americans forgive them these things
called prairie cakes which were insects
mixed with various vegetables and they
thought they were delicious until they
found out what they were made out of I
think a lot of the reasons that we don't
eat insects here in the United States is
just actually because of European
culture Europe's a pretty cool place for
the most part not a lot of huge
delicious tropical insects and so Europe
didn't have too much of it in second
culture and when they came the United
States kind of killed off but in fact
eating culture that we had here with the
Native American okay so the farming
process yeah yes let's talk about this
okay this is obviously a big question
you know where do you get your crickets
or where do they come from and actually
one of my favorite things about insects
because you can urban farm crickets so
if you think about the food system
there's lots of problems with our with
our
but normally you have to grow cows and
pigs out in the countryside right but
you can grow crickets any kind of
warehouse so when you think about a
cricket environments usually like a big
warehouse with shelving units do we need
free-range crickets a really is a really
big question actually they're not free
rain is that you can't wild harvest
insects because you just don't know what
they've gotten into especially in our
polluted world you have to make sure
that you know what they're eating and
cricket farmers are incredibly sanitary
incredibly controlled they won't eat
each other we need each other if they're
properly cared for if you put too many
crickets
you know you close together that's where
you know where it comes in where you
have to have the proper environment
everything like that yeah yeah so
basically you have a big warehouse full
of bins bins yeah like give it enough
space but a lot with egg cartons and
like a little create Department and
there's some great pictures Google
cricket farm you'll get some good
pictures what they look like but what's
neat about it is because they're in they
can be in urban areas you can feed them
on food waste I don't mean food waste
like I mean food waste in terms of the
local grocery store has too much lettuce
for that week normally they'd have to
throw it out and they could
hypothetically bring it out to the farms
in the country but the transportation
costs are really high but if you have it
locally even feed that lettuce to the
crickets in the cricket farm and then
reduce the distance from a table as well
because now you've got the crickets
right there in the city where people
need them are are we normally feeding
critias lettuce I mean crickets can eat
think of them like a pest in your garden
right they can eat all sorts of
different vegetable matter so it's
actually louder so it's normally
basically vegetables mixed with often
how like a cricket feed that gives them
some extra vitamins and minerals do we
know they can I mean they can eat all
sorts of different things so often that
you'll have extra proteins or like you
can add extra iron or rickets are
depending on what you feed them you can
change their nutrition and taste quite a
bit so you'll form different firms will
formulate their crickets and the half
different element
in order to supplement their cricket and
make them as healthy as you know if you
can okay so then you you have a farm
yourself a warehouse in Austin Texas no
we don't but we work with cricket
farmers all over who are growing these
farms and making this cricket
I mean cricket farming has been going on
for a long time no have you
yeah you've explored the business of
sourcing from farmers versus starting
your own and it just makes more sense
the source is they already have it down
we thought about this and we thought
about do we start our own cricket farm
and and you have a question of like what
part of this supply chain do we want to
be on but ultimately you can have
billions of crickets but if no one's
buying them it doesn't really matter and
so what we were more interested in is
how do we change people's minds how do
we get them more excited about eating
insects and then you know then that's
where it matters the whole supply chain
and the cricket farms and all of that
but we have to start with changing minds
and so that's where we where we realized
that we had the most experience we are
not cricket farmers we have no
experience growing crickets and a lot of
the farmers have been doing it for
generations so it's like you know what
the cricket farmers with generations of
experience work on that and we'll start
on actually creating something that will
eat meat out of bug yes and then you
guys are on the inspiration and
marketing and distribution side of
things okay so you're sourcing from the
u.s. mostly Midwest part yeah I mean
we're starting to look into where else
can we get crickets from because we
talked about people eat insects all over
the world so that's also really exciting
but you know right now mostly here in
the night state with potential for
growth everywhere I mean you can imagine
a pretty cool model where there was a
delicious worm groaning Zimbabwe and you
could give those local worm primaries a
market here in the United States but
there's some more barriers you have to
don't over to important section one and
then turn it into something that people
would eat it sorry yeah I mean you're
talking about the larger vision for a
minute what's exciting about insect is
that you can make all sorts of different
foods from them right I mean they aren't
animal-based
so you're usually making this from the
flower you could but actually um what I
think would be very exciting with a make
a meat replacement with them because for
a very long time we've been trying to
make plants these mechanicals but plants
and animals are fundamentally pretty
different right it's hard to make a
plant piece like an animal well now we
have the whole clean meat movement as
well where we're actually just growing
it from there's growing with Sally we're
working on different ways to do what's
this
oh yeah well here it was a great example
so this is a mealworm falafel I think we
need a better word than mealworm but my
arms actually have a pretty similar
thing like taste like beef if I were to
give this to you right now and you
didn't know what it was you'd think it
tasted pretty good and so I've been
doing a lot of experimenting and that's
this you're right
yes exactly this is a mule no insects
already are an animal based protein and
so it's all a nine essential amino acids
it's a complete protein and you can
create tastes that are much more similar
to other animal animal meat and you can
from a plant and with a lot less process
like it takes a lot of processing to
make a veggie burger actually tastes
like me me now you're also interested in
like meal worm so you're interested in
other insects I mean you know you have
to start somewhere and I think if I
would ask you would you rather eat a
meal worm or do you rather eat a cricket
you know I mean now that I've a dick you
know I'll definitely eat a meal worm
nice they call it so we call crickets
our gateway by date way but like what's
the easiest eat anything
um one reason we throw at the picket but
worms have an especially scary
connotation like no fear factor in oh
and gooey which is actually one reason
why we're working with chips because
chips are crunchy and so it helps a
little bit with that worry of biting
into something squishy which i think is
one of the trigger points for people
with yes so okay so walk me back us
through this so we take the we we freeze
freeze
then just grind is just supposed to
roast it yeah so you know stuff huh
right roast and then grind into a powder
so it was similar way you'd make any
kind of powder flour is the very fine
grinding process until it looks just
kind of like awful wheat flour
and then from here then you now you sell
this as well as the cricket flour and
you can put that into ease or what other
kind of things really anything I mean
you can make a pizza crust it could make
a cookie you could make banana bread
there's so many different options and
you just replace a percentage of the
regular flour with the cricket powder
and you get a lot more protein vitamins
and minerals it's like a little bit of a
nutty taste to it the pancake yeah pink
cricket pancakes are amazing that's
interesting out so yeah we're selling
the flour so that you can make it
yourself and maybe you shouldn't maybe
sell a pygmy
you know there's possibilities we sell
cookie mix already oh you guys know
you'd yeah that's right cookie mixes we
have not here you laughs good I think
I'm saying that okay okay cool the
cookie mix is actually amazing I would
HIGHLY highly recommend it the I really
want you to bring it next time next time
this cricket cookies sound mmm the
alliteration is also interesting herbs
chips chocolate chocolate chip cookies
chocolate chocolate sure cricket cookies
chocolate chip cookies chocolate you're
pretty shocked okay I hear what you did
there you don't know literation it's
quite good okay so now okay so now let's
keep going so we have the flour and then
now for the chips at least you're adding
corn yeah so our chips I mean it's
basically just corn brick any ideas with
chia seeds and basically just seasoning
mix all up and well are you get chips so
I actually this so this is interesting
enough this was my first time trying
these and I really I really I really
liked them a lot this is the old
packaging but I still like it it's very
it's very friendly and like the two
little like the two little ears yeah
you're right
it really doesn't taste I mean it's just
a little bit blue like nutty last people
sometimes the difference she people
don't really know quite how to describe
what a cricket tastes like and that's a
little bit of depth to it I think I
think you're right about that movie yeah
one cricket Bert that's right so you
can't count your crickets as you go you
work a lot with kids you like to count
the crickets is it all soon
like this no the crickets as well I
haven't tried the this one yeah this is
this is your new packaging yes this is
any packaging and a loose believer I
like the new packaging it's definitely a
box you know because it's not the white
and black and then you kind of got cool
red and green on it we've kind of gone
more to embrace the eat bugs cuz if you
look at the old packaging yeah let's see
it does the eat bugs or on this Oh a bit
smaller this is ah that's a really good
point
is that we went from chirps being the
biggest thing to now being eat bugs
that's a good I like that yeah you thank
you I'm excited to try this rock to
flavor these are really good yeah this
is well done hmm majority of the
ingredients are just stone ground corn
yeah and then the target protein blend
yeah and then everything else is just
seasoning it's pretty general season
it's just basically this is sera chess
and we just you know peppers and salsa
yeah it tastes really well thank you I
mean in one serving and get 5 grams of
protein so it's a much prettier one
Vegas 5 grams well you can angle you
could eat a little bag of chips we'll
think of it as normally you don't get
routine when you're eating chips right
and really you just get empty carbs and
so it's a way to get some more protein
and gets more nutrients yeah
are you considering going for a larger
like the Brandt bugs like I mean it's
been interesting questions so this
original packaging it's really cute
we've got little chirpy guy here but the
problem was that when it was on shelves
it was just getting lost
there's Soleil chips that you file and
so we went to the new packaging that
says we bugs with yeah with the black
and white because ultimately people are
gonna find out there's bugs on it
there's no - right so it's a little
controversial but if you see eat bugs
and big letters you can like it or you
can dislike it but at least you're going
to notice it at least you're gonna be
able to have an opinion on it and you
know maybe even try it the first time
for novelty and then realize oh well
this actually tastes good share it with
your friends and start this larger
movement cuz when we pull this bag
you're making a statement you're saying
I eat bugs
versus like this it's a little bit less
clear of what you're saying is you're
weird that's a good point
well done on the packaging design really
well done
I like it a lot it's very clean and it
definitely is pushing that eat bugs and
you are making that payment yeah
BBQ cheddar sea salt sriracha yeah those
are the four right now yeah cool and we
got a discount code well yeah we'll
definitely simulation and percent off
the order at checkout give eat bugs to
go definitely a fun thing to bring to
your party that probably be my
recommendation if you want to try it
figure out when you're next back
together with friends at us cuz chips
are super social product and it would be
a conversation all about sustainability
and food people probably won't even know
the difference but uh and then you can
be the one that they all say Oh
Helen was the one that introduced me to
crickets yeah you got to be the
girlfriend yeah yeah yeah
Ron also got to try the chips what did
you what did you think Ron oh I I think
you were at something happening on
Market Street a few months back you were
um I forget the venue it was down the
street aways and I and I think I had
some there as well so yeah I'm a big fan
and um you know five five grams of
protein per BEC it has the the
vegetarian vegan
platform do given you a hard time yeah
they all they give you our time do we
have that stamp of the vegetarian
approval if you eat insects so it's
an interesting question and it's what I
love having with vegetarians because it
begs the question why am i vegetarian
right and so we're thinking about it as
another option so some vegetarians are
all about it like if you're vegetarian
for sustainability reasons insects are
more sustainable than many plant-based
sources so one gallon of water for a
pound of insects versus 2,000 gallons of
water for a pound of beef yeah
that's massive difference yeah I mean in
terms of land usage what are you since
these are more sustainable than man-made
sources and so a lot of vegetarians are
like this is amazing yeah this is a way
that I can get b12 for example which you
normally only get brown and obey sources
it's sustainable but you know it's not
for everybody I'd say it's 5050 and
really depends on why you know why
you're about the period if you we're
good it's also from a you know a moral
perspective I wrecked my bike there but
um so I'm really against our factory
departments I think it's pretty terrible
this thick really really large animals
in small cages but what's good about
insects is that you they're pretty small
animals might need a lot less space to
be happy right you've got a beehive over
an anthill that has a natural small
space and so as long as you're growing
them in a you know sustainable were away
which you can with insects this makes a
lot more sense to me so for many
vegetarians it's a good answer we don't
ever pressure people some people are
saying no you know a bug is an animal
and it doesn't make sense to me but the
more choices that we can give people we
think the better it's actually a term
for it so if you what is the term you
can be an int o terian and tote area
like a pescetarian yeah yeah and
entertain it inside with insects in tow
means anything into terian I'm there
plants that that uh
that eat bugs also though you know
that's where the yeah right so you know
come on there's no ha there's no end to
the argument and another question that
probably vegetarian
interesting it's like Oh how much
conscious instead of that versus like a
dog or cat or a power a bacon as we see
varying levels of ocean well we know
certain things like most insects don't
have pain receptors so that's a big one
yeah right they don't have a nervous
system it's I mean very slowly they're
incredibly limited central nervous
system so you know again everything's a
spectrum right from bacteria to humans
and so insects are further down that so
you kind of have to start thinking you
know what where am i comfortable what
makes sense for me well how what level
of consciousness will I start I think
like plants even seem to when you know
when you cut off a part of a plant
they'll often communicate with each
other or send out stress responses and
so you know it's it's all a larger
conversation nothing's ever black and
white and but for me the fact that they
don't feel pain is definitely a booing
yeah so we have a good slide up here as
well yeah walk us through this why eat
bugs
definitely so and on the background here
is the livestock industry is one of the
biggest contributors to environmental
problem so half of the freshwater in the
United States goes the lives I can see
that's a fuckload half it's absolutely
insane and that's mostly to things like
these pound of beef that you thousand
gallons of water it's just so yes so
much water you've had a one of our
friends is Benjamin Grant who does the
satellite I mean he has a satellite
photo of this cow farm in Texas
and it's just massive there's little
tiny dot all cows and this is all raizy
a lot of them and actually on that point
like we skip down to the greenhouse gas
emissions when you go by those areas you
smell it right because these cows are
letting off so much methane is
concentrated in those areas yes it's
intense
you know versus crickets it's like a
hundred times less for the same amount
of me I mean across all of the adults
it's seeing the same kind of comparing
contrast of hundreds of times now
better in the food miles also us a lot
in terms of energy to move food with the
destination being mm-hmm food waste is
crazy in the u.s. that's a that's a
really big I wonder if it that high in
China I mean all around you've got this
problem where you're growing your cow is
off in the country and then needing to
ship them all over yeah so Russ insects
can answer so many of these questions at
the end of this after eating insects and
looking these statistics it's like why
aren't we eating bugs and the answer is
really just you know that's the mental
game though and so that's been obviously
our mission is how do we change that how
do we change minds why don't we bring
eating insects means yeah nice this is
this is super educational I'm really
loving it yeah and it's also
inspirational because I think that when
you take a life experience like you guys
going the countries and then seeing what
culture does and then saying that
interesting how can we bring some of
this back Wes yeah and then you go and
start a business and you become
entrepreneurs and then you get inspire
other people to air about this and
understand it more and environmentally
it makes sense so it is it is very
inspirational or this is awesome well
thank you yeah so okay so now you've
done some really interesting stuff as
well with you've done you did a blood
test and then you went and you ate
insects for a week
yeah so I mean really a month so it's
all kind of started because I realized
that even though I have this bug company
I'm a co-founder
it's not like I'm eating bugs for every
meal and I was like if I'm not eating
bugs as a regular part of my diet how
can I expect anyone else to be doing
this and so kind of started this
challenge where for a month I decided to
eat insects for every single meal and
you know see how I felt
see what tastes been good and so
beforehand I did all of my blood work
okay now quick questions yeah would you
eat a normal meal and just add a couple
chips to it or would you take the flour
and make a meal with flour well all
sorts of different different iterations
right
you know definitely had snack on some
troops but it was mostly about beyond
trips like the future of what this could
look like oh we have a really phone call
from the universe but basically you know
for example making a yogurt parfait and
then adding ants so ants for example are
kind of sour when they bite it hurts
because they have formic acid when you
eat them tastes like lemon and so it
depends on the kind of an ascender
little spicy the ones I was eating
mostly lemony and so you can add them in
there's actually a picture in here
somewhere
you're really tinkering yeah yeah that's
cool I mean top chefs are working with
insects now it's from a culinary
perspective it's this top chefs are now
undiscovered 3 group yeah that's cool
what picture are we looking for
oh the food you see one let's see
there's a coup brulee for example with
earlier so this is a cooling and
ordinarily might make a lemon creme
brulee but we did it with ants because
you get that same sourness interesting
and so chefs will whoa yes Ernie uses a
see like notice for example one of the
top restaurants in the world works with
insects because there's so many
interesting flavors I think we talked
about this one well it's a worm what was
it worm what was that one a new meal
worms
yes emiru is an answer you're tinkering
for a month with different every single
meal just adding these in and seeing
what could happen like this is a banana
bread but we use the cricket flour and
so we get a lot more protein and
nutrients from it I don't and like I
kind of nutty in any taste at all
so yeah I mean there were some insect
dishes that I cooked that were amazing
and something that I was like don't
recommend this I mean it's kind of like
any food it's like learning how to cook
with chicken like what you do with it
how do you cook it and you know that was
my month experiment and then um took
kind of my favorite recipes and put them
together so you go onto our social media
you can find some of our recipes the
whole blog about it about what actually
worked well what we recommend and then
the last week I ate all
but yeah just to kind of you know more
of an experiment of like what happens
yeah and then did my homework and what
were the about oh well kind of most
exciting thing was as a vegetarian
before might be twelve levels were
borderline low and because we talked
about beat both get from animal based
sources and after the month of eating
bugs my b12 levels had increased - right
right in the right place like
significantly into the middle range and
so like it's amazing you can actually
increase your b12 levels by eating
insects and other biomarkers how did
they really change that much I mean you
know I was pretty healthy individual
before yeah was you know what's healthy
afterwards um a loss of two pounds which
was interesting I think
insects are pretty high in protein and
so you know I just felt a lot more
satiated than I normally would but
besides that you know it's extra food
and by replacing you know what you might
have with me that with insects not much
changes it's just just another food
source so interesting okay so you have
now you have chips you are moving into a
little bit of cookie no yeah we've got a
cookie mix great fun and holiday gift or
fun thing that they got and then you're
exploring potentially other insects
other insects and then we also sell the
cricket powder powders yeah so now this
is kind of you know your vision and
where you're building this out what do
you think then the future of food we
were talking a little bit about clean me
yeah yeah we're growing me from cells
this interesting work we more people are
eating insects which are much more
environmentally friendly build proteins
build where do you think this all
heading yeah I mean I just think that
these are all gonna be options and I
know and pushing insects to be part of
that conversation around me right this
is a big problem of this is not a
sustainable way to you saw all the
statistics around our meat industry and
so that's why there's all of these
different solutions popping up like
lab-grown meat and how do we you know
the impossible burger and some of these
other solutions of maybe we can make
plants the
like animals and kind of our solution
here is we have a protein source that
we've been eating since the dawn of men
that tastes good and is good for the
world and needs a lot less processing
for example then a plant-based source
toothpaste like me so let's bring this
into the conversation as well and so
kind of what the future holds I mean
what we're looking at is walking into
your local grocery store and having
insect powders of various kinds and all
sorts of different things
Emily how you'd you know flip something
over and see away or a soy protein you
just I've been sacks on all sorts of
different product and in the meat arena
you might walk into your local
restaurant and you could get a beef
burger or a university on high universe
yes so nervous so you could get a beef
burger a chicken burger or a bug burger
might be called an into a burger or a
chirps burger you know whatever it's
called and those would all be options
and all ways for people to eat more
sustainably I like the idea of the walk
grocery store and seeing they like the
it's like flowers they make stuff like
see your recipes and go and try those
recipes out it's just I mean right now
it's shocking right and the goal is for
it to not the goal is it for it to just
be oh yeah there's bugs on this in it to
not be a discussion for this show that
we're having right now to be irrelevant
because this is no longer an interesting
conversation this is just the way that
we the way that we eat yep I hope that
in 15 years you know you don't have a
backbone yourself you will in 15 years
you come back on the show cuz you're
gonna have new product lines there yeah
yeah but it'll be normalized you know
it'll be normalized and you'll be doing
some other kind of crazy visionary work
with stainability
food do you have to make it into a
powder like could you have like a
cricket pizza just take the actual whole
cricket and just you know like an
anchovy
I think this metaphor about like the
gateway bug and it's possible right so
kind of an interesting example is the
Seattle Mariners the baseball team
they're selling bull grasshoppers at
their baseball games
they've been selling out every single
game and that's because people like what
sells grasshoppers yeah in their food so
it's just like a little container of
seasoned grasshoppers in Mexico they're
called chuckling Eason yeah a really
common snack what dnews and so basically
they've just been selling them and
what'll happen is a group of friends
don't have one adventurous friend who
will want to try it and then hand out
the grasshoppers everybody's been and
then you're eating them whole you are
and that's the shocking part is we're
here talking about grinding them into a
different format and yet you've got some
satellites over there eating whole bugs
so uh we're not quite there yet over the
whole country but I think there's a
possibility over I think for right now
this cricket flour forget protein and
performer like a chips probably an
easier in Tibet hmm couple quick
questions on the way on the way out
thoughts for you Mia just one more time
you okay now we're good okay first
question is we asked this question a lot
and I think it's important to ask you
because you're so focused on
sustainability food there's quite a bit
of exponential technology that's
happening across different fields and
it's exacerbating wealth gap quite a bit
and on the bottom solely coming up and
rocketing upward what do you think is
kind of gonna happen with that you know
are you talking about cricket
specifically here or in general
socio-economic yeah I mean I think
unless something changes its this is a
reality I don't have any you know
particular insights besides that it is
happening and I think Rose my co-founder
and I were discussing whether in our
lifetimes we're gonna see the first
trillionaire and I think there's a
significant possibility that we will we
will we absolutely well especially
because of artificial intelligence and
robotics and automation yeah that's you
know help I mean an interesting thing in
our field is that Amazon bought Whole
Foods yeah and so we're seeing even in
the food industry technology creeping in
and kind of taking over and we've been
seeing a lot of small grocery stores
shutting down because people are buying
their food on Amazon more often
Millennials don't actually want to go to
their local grocery store and so you
know like it's a problem don't you know
maybe it is the future and but if it
gets monopolized by one company then
then what I mean and maybe if Amazon's
prices are so low and that maybe it's
not that everything who knows I mean
it's a tough I mean it's an interesting
one even with picots because we've got
these automated farms for cows and
chickens and pigs and it's something
we're a little bit worried about for
crickets is what happens when we have
all of these automated factory farming
how do we make sure that we build a
system that is more sustainable with
crickets than with other animal sources
and it's something that we're conscious
of as we're building this not create
another monstrosity not to replace one
problem with another the point I have to
ask for years looking at the blockchain
technology for your profits at all you
know this comes up a lot like good not
yet where should you very much focus
they in the food industry and know much
cheese yeah well keep you posted tell
your bags of chips on the centralized
yep yeah decentralized crickets I don't
know yeah I have to ask it's just so
funny is it's so hype and there's a lot
of really good uses for it but then
there's also like if you would be like
yeah we're using boxing now and there is
for the food system there is interesting
ways to leverage the decentralized
digital logic has been in conversation
for sure yeah to make sure that where
you're sourcing it from is the actual
location that you're getting it from all
this I mean you know in that case in
that larger context I'm sure at some
point if we figure out block chains for
the whole food systems it could be tied
in but we're not you know we're not
currently yeah we smell the food
industry is old like we still fax things
this is this is the reality so block
chains are a little a little bit of a
distant future you're still like faxing
your purchase orders and stuff slowly
dying out but yeah
we had to get a fax number when we first
started this because it was the only way
to communicate with some of the with
that well I mean yeah with different
distributors and stores even they wanted
they wanted a faxed order yeah there's
apps on your smartphone luckily there
yeah yeah another thing that I was
thinking about was every time somebody
buys a bag of chirps they can get a trip
point they can turn in their chirp coins
for for currency for bet more bags of
chips whatever it's alliteration yeah
totally yeah run with it yeah please
these ideas are not mine they just run
through me and outs of the world yeah
that's interesting so okay how about we
how about we ask you do you think that
we're alone in the cosmos oh my goodness
no there's no way I mean that's my
personal belief but like there's so many
planets like just from a statistical
point of view the conditions needed in
order to create life-forms that are
similar to ours with the number of
planets and the number of conditions it
seems highly probable if there's other
intelligent life out there whether we
have communicated with them and all of
that I think is still you know the
larger question and it's still up in the
air do you think there's another Laura
to sorrow on some other rock orbiting a
star building or you know not sure I
think that's a little bit less likely
similar to you know there's each
snowflake is different right and there's
some snowflakes that are much more
similar so I'm sure there are other
human beings that even on planet Earth
that look like me are more similar to me
and got the universe perhaps but exactly
the same seems mm-hmm less likely but no
more I'm an expert on crickets then the
cosmos definitely like that bringing
another guess - it was like - we like to
dip people into multidisciplinary fields
of thinking as well so that's why we we
pull people in okay do more all right
this one is do you think we're in a
simulation yeah you know what friends
have been talking about this lately I'm
gonna go No
I mean I know that people say that it's
against epistle II it could be probable
but I just like to believe that this is
real whether you know no I don't think
there's enough information to really
know but uh I'm gonna go with no and
that we'll see how that pans out we're
trying to hack into the fabric of
reality to see if we can get in the
answer yeah okay and last question is
what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing in the world in the world ah
that's a great question um I mean the
first thing I I come to think of is best
nature you go to somewhere outside of
everything that humans have built I
think the things humans have built are
incredible but they often aren't even as
perfect as the things that the world has
on its own like if you look at a
seashell for example just the beautiful
patterns that are inside it or you're
out in the middle of a field and looking
at the way that a piece of grass grows
you sacred geometries and fractals all
of that it's you know it's really
incredible and I think that we often
think that we can make things that are
better than nature and I've replaced a
lot of nature but I still think that
there's so much inspiration from all the
things that are not man-made yeah that's
something I'm worried about losing that
as technology progresses and virtual
reality
I think there's times for our reality to
not be augmented yeah like that look
good there's times for a reality to not
be honest so just this normal system of
perception that we have five senses and
not be augmented
people to I don't know feel plants and
see you like magnetism and also there oh
yeah but just to slow down and be in
nature and also interestingly enough we
addressed so much towards metropolitan
areas and now densely populated in
skyscraper of that now we have to like
let me make trips out to nature some
visit nature is such a strange concept
right you know our ancestors would think
that was
pretty ridiculous yeah yeah I'm glad
that I'm glad you brought that up that's
that's a good one it's really a deep
appreciation for our world around us
yeah this has been such a pleasure holy
cow
thanks for coming on cricket holy
cricket okay it's so funny no more
saying holy cow no cows were in the past
crickets in the future
holy cricket come nice ring to it
doesn't it that's funny
I love it okay awesome so Ari well what
a great project is well sustainably
focused on sustainability some focus on
convincing people that eating insects is
cool and it's been cool for a while and
now it's time to make it more cool yeah
so yeah than it and if you be always you
try cooking with insects let us know how
it goes we're always looking for more
recipes and more ideas shirts chips on
Instagram yep chirp chips on instagram
tag them
let's see your let's see what you make
with the flowers simulation 10% off at
checkout go check it out
thanks for tuning in everybody if you
guys had a good time go share the
content to other people to go talk to
them about like hey you want to eat some
insects like those got to go get a bag
from store what stores are you guys in
over you can check our store locator at
trips tips calm or amazon is most
products is there yes get them on Amazon
check out the store locator as well get
them near you go get some goat Rhyme be
that person that brings them to a party
and it's just like hey you want to eat
an insect that's great
go share it with people also go make
something with this don't just consume
the content will create go write about
it go read about it go create with it
also subscribe join us talk about us in
the community we'd love to help foster
that and join us on patreon help us
sustain this help us grow and help us
impact more people thanks for tuning
ever everyone
much love
[Music]